Jimmy Fallon yeah did you do impressions
yeah that was my that was my thing whoa
thank you very much don't find out why
if you come and watch a great and kick
and balan check how would how would step
look how would stir okay people okay
we're walking why don't we just take a
bus
bossun hey you know another guy sure I
can't believe this this like crazy boom
here like them two rats Andy Steve
Harvey what you're doing is a joyous
beautiful game show where families get
to feud like duh winning I know there's
a lot of talent in Saugerties New York
could you come down please
with my hair back with my hair back and
forth
you gotta whip your hair yeah yeah yeah
mr. Wayne you are forgetting Oh your
problems I'm hitting out every light
fixture for symmetry better brighter
where do you see what they call kid but
as for breakfast no I don't know Fredo
Fredo knows
Fredo knows exactly and then nothing
whoa whoa AEI what's this chris Christie
backstage a strippers g-string what what
do you what does shake it off I was out
the other day with Rickles so I know
those sketch I've seen it
sing with Brian Williams I can't slow
Jim only you could change the colors of
the hallways this is ridiculous I mean
do you like cars
haha you know when I was a kid we used
to get like metal things like tin
whistles now you get a picture of a
[ __ ] snake
you
you